[Music]
here's your money briefing for Tuesday
March 7th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
more married couples are checking the
married filing separately box on their
tax return so what are the benefits and
what are the pitfalls to watch for when
choosing that option let's bring in Wall
Street Journal tax reporter Laura
Saunders for some answers hey Laura
thanks for being with us thanks so much
for having me so Laura how common is
this married couples filing separately
well it's not very common there are
about 160 million tax returns and
they're about 4 million people that's 2
million couples who file separate tax
returns that is use the married filing
separately category so it's not many
people but it's the only one that's been
growing and has gone up about 50 percent
in the last decade now some of that in
like 2019 and 20 had to do with people
filing separately to qualify for
pandemic benefits however it had been
going up before that so how does the IRS
view people who file separately are they
considered individual filers well well
let's stop right there for a minute it's
not up to the IRS I think we all need to
remember oh you always school me on this
yes exactly that congress makes the tax
law the IRS enforces it and so how does
the tax law view married filing
separately taxpayers are they like two
single people the answer is no it's a
complicated status to choose and it may
cost you or it may bring you a benefit
and there are different reasons for
doing it but you remain married in the
eyes of the law you're just filing
separate tax returns you know when you
look at the tax return you see single
and married they probably don't even
know this married filing separately
option is there well I think a lot of
people know it's there but other people
see it on the return they say what is
this and in fact some CPAs say this is
the most asked question and that's
because married couples may not choose
to file separately but they want to know
what it means okay I want to go into all
the pros and cons of doing this in just
a moment moment but is this option of
filing married but separately is this
available only on the federal return no
it's very available with many states and
you need to pay attention to the state
tax implications because in some states
you cannot file separately for the state
unless you filed it separately for the
feds and there's a lot there especially
if you live in community property States
and things like that so you need to
always pay attention to state tax
implications as well as Federal all
right so let's talk about some of the
pros and cons of doing this what is it
about people's finances that would make
checking the married filing separately
button makes sense well the most
important reason may be one that doesn't
necessarily save you on your tax bill
and it is that and it's an old
long-standing reason married filing
separately it's Sever's joint liability
for what's on the tax return now if you
file jointly with your spouse each
person is completely liable for all that
information so if your spouse is
cheating or doing something illegal you
could be liable for taxes on that so
married filing separately severs that
liability and for some people that's so
important they don't care if it costs
some money or Not by the way those are
often people who are getting divorced
but it could be married people often in
a second or third marriage that don't
want responsibility for each other's
finances now one couple I talked to for
this story is in another situation they
were very happily married but one in
particular has a lot of student debt he
is a professional musician with a degree
from a very prestigious school and he is
in an income driven repayment program
for his student debt and that is based
on what his disposable income is and so
if he and his wife file separately then
his income is lower so his debt
repayment is lower and at some point the
debt will be forgiven but why while he's
paying it it will be much lower and this
by the way is a fully legal thing to do
to file separately when you're married
if you're paying student debt based on
income so outside of their situation and
more broadly speaking what would filing
separately mean for someone's tax bill
well you probably wouldn't want to do it
unless it reduces your tax bill absent
these other situations and okay let's
say one reason that comes up is that say
one spouse has very large medical
expenses and so they aren't deductible
except to the extent they exceed 7.5
percent of adjusted gross income if you
split The spouse's income then you might
get a much bigger deduction so that
would be a good example you mentioned
medical deductions how about Medicare
what if a spouse is on Medicare Medicare
has something called Irma these are
where you make payments for Part B and
Part D based on your income and the
rules for Irma change if you're married
filing separately they're less generous
and so it still could work out well but
you need to pay very close attention to
the numbers and also what happens for
example if a spouse owns a business well
that could be a good reason to file
separately there's a wonderful deduction
of 20 percent called qualified business
income it came in with the 2017 tax
overhaul and it's a straight off the top
deduction from taxable income but if you
have say a business owner of a
successful business married to someone
who has maybe a corporate job your
income might be too high to qualify for
this so if you split the income then
maybe one partner in the couple the
business owner could qualify for it and
that might be a good thing all right so
a lot of benefits here for some people
but I feel like that there's a butt
coming yes there is
um of course always with taxes by law
married couples filing separately just
don't get certain tax breaks they can't
deduct the interest on student loans
that's a twenty five hundred dollar
deduction they also can't take the
American Opportunity and lifetime
learning credits the Child Independent
care tax credit also maybe a larger
percent image of Social Security
benefits might be taxable so this is
something to pay attention to oh and one
other thing that's really important it
affects your contributions to IRAs and
Roth IRAs This is complicated you need
to go look up the rules which are pretty
easy to file online but if you want to
make a direct contribution to a Roth IRA
and you have more than ten thousand
dollars of income you can't do it of
course there's a workaround you could do
a backdoor Roth contribution but there
are all these like pitfalls and traps
and things like that a good amount of
homework to be done about your own
personal financial situation yes you
really have to run the numbers unless
you want to get out of that joint
liability then you don't care about the
numbers so what if a couple of foresees
their marital status changing during the
tax year well that's something to pay
attention to and the rules on that can
be pretty complicated and whether the
person is living in the house or not
living in the house and if their
children involved and things like that
so I think people should go to read
publication 5 501 which has to do with
filing status and the rules are pretty
well laid out there so that's a place to
start you might need professional help
some people say that the year you get
divorced or the year you get married or
have a child those are good times to get
professional help and that form would be
on irs.gov well it's a publication IRS
publication 501 and it is on irs.gov and
it's a little booklet that lays out the
tax law all right so people's personal
finances could change from year to year
how would that affect their ability to
file separately well there's good news
and there's bad news the good news is
that married couples can switch back and
forth between filing separately and
filing jointly so they could file
separately in some years and jointly and
others and also married filing
separately taxpayers can later amend
their tax return to go from separate to
Joint but what you can't do is if you
file jointly you can't split it later on
and file separately on an amended return
details details exactly all right that's
Wall Street Journal tax reporter Laura
Saunders with us Laura thanks so much
for being with us and thank you and
that's your money briefing I'm J.R
Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
foreign
[Music]